good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van
horn from the university of virginia and i
am very proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2021 2022 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series this lecture series
is supported by uva's integrated translational
health institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the national institutes of general medical
sciences this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
every friday we enjoy presentations from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected participants in
our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held
here in june in charlottesville virginia today i
am delighted to welcome not one but two speakers
dr Sallie ann keller and dr stephanie shipp
from the uva biocomplexity institute here at
the university of virginia Sallie ann keller is
a distinguished professor in biocomplexity the
director of the social and decision analytics
division of the biocomplexity institute
and professor of public health sciences her areas
of expertise are social and decision informatics
statistical underpinnings of data science and data
access and confidentiality she is a leading voice
in creating the science of all data and advancing
this research across disciplines to benefit
society stephanie ship is deputy director and
professor of the social and decision analytics
division um her areas of expertise are economic
policy analysis and evaluation her work spans
topics related to the science of data science
community analytics and ethics she is a leading
and engaging person in projects at the local state
and federal levels to assess data quality and use
of new and traditional data sources to advance
the public good in continuing our 2021-2022
biomedical data science seminar series theme
sallie and stephanie's lecture today is entitled
data acumen in action sallie and stephanie
will drive home the idea that data science is
the quintessential translational research field
that starts at the point of translation the real
problem to be solved it involves many stakeholders
across fields of practice and lends itself to team
science consequently data science has evolved
into a powerful transdisciplinary endeavor and
doing public oriented data science has revealed
that many of the consumers in this research
do not have sufficient data acumen and thus can be
overwhelmed with how to use data-driven insights
sallie and stephanie will rightly note that
it's unrealistic to think that most decision
makers are data scientists and so we have a
lot of work to do in training them because
even with domain knowledge some literacy and
data science remains useful as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you are watching on youtube today
thank you so much for joining us our specially
selected 2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are encouraged to
submit any questions for sallie and stephanie
via the chat feature in their zoom sessions i will
synthesize these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so of their
lecture and with that sallie and stephanie welcome
we are so excited to hear from you today thank
you jack um this is sallie i'm going to start
and i'll be handing off to stephanie
about midway through the presentation
i thought i would start today by just sharing
with you a little bit about the biocomplexity
institute at university of virginia it's a
very unique organization it's a freestanding
research institute within the university um
it's reporting lines like uh the deans of
schools is directly to the provost and the span of
research in this institute is really exciting it
ranges from mathematical biocomplexity theoretical
mathematics around omics genomics sequencing
what we might have called bioinformatics of years
gone by but that really theoretical mathematical
uh level of things and then it starts to move
through from sort of the molecular level into
other behavioral scales into massive simulations
around people and movements of people and places
and that's our network system science and advanced
computing division so some of the coveted model
coven modeling that you've seen coming out of
university of virginia that's helped to support
the state of virginia uh new york city
and other places have come out of this
particular group among other things and then as
you sort of drive towards evidence-based policy
you start to uh engage with the research of our
division the social decision analytics division
and because of this really strong policy
focus of our work we're actually situated
up here in northern virginia to make sure
that we wake up every morning remembering
that we're in the policy capital of the world
and that we're keeping our eyes and our um
our eyes wide open on how we can bring our work
to bear on important public policy so that's us
and so now we're going to start and i always like
to start by just reminding ourself what is data
science because this is all about data science
and and uh you know ethical issues related to data
science well what the heck is data science anyway
um and as you know jack said we view data science
as a science that starts at the point of
translation because it is in the context of
real problems i like to remind people that if we
don't have a problem there's no real data science
you know ai machine learning uh statistical
methods all of these things are tools that we
use in data science they not they are not in and
of themselves data science at least in my opinion
um and what's really important too is to remember
that if you're going to focus on problems problem
solutions require carefully framed questions and
that will play a role as we talk about data acumen
we have had a lot of data science partners in
our work we're in our ninth year as a research
organization and we have done research with
sponsors from industry from local state and
federal agencies from local governments and also
from dod most specifically the army recently
another thing that's really important to
remember is that data science is a team sport
and there you see part of our team and it's really
about engaging together across disciplines across
areas of expertise to come together and bring
the best that you can to a particular problem
okay so let's talk about what we're calling
data acumen which may be a new term for you
and data acumen the definition that we like to use
is the ability to make good judgments about
the use of data to support problem solutions
let's unpack that when we talk about use of
data the first question that should come to mind
is what the heck are data and we're going to talk
about that it's not necessarily an obvious answer
and then this issue of
supporting problem solutions
what comes to mind there is how do you trust the
use of the results for data informed decisions
now there are levels of data acumen many of you
in the audience are data scientists you're trained
in statistics or computer science quantitative
methods applied math some of you are probably
subject matter experts that you're trained in a
particular field um some of you may cross over
between those two things and some of you or at
least a lot of the people that we work directly
with are consumers of data science and of these
data science applications they're neither a
data scientist you know or a particular subject
matter expert but the information is coming to
them and they have to consume it so you know the
question is which are you let you think about that
but when we think of helping people become
consumers when we think of helping the
communication between data scientists and subject
matter experts that's where trying to think about
how do you actually frame and characterize
data acumen so we can all grow more of it
so when we think about data acumen and when
we think about the people that we work with
on our research teams with our sponsors we
have a set of questions that we like to keep
in the front of our mind to make sure we're
walking through as we're working with them
and the first one is you know what is the
problem or the question that they're trying to
uh that they're trying to address again data
science is about bringing data together to
help support a problem and a problem solution
what kinds of decisions are they trying to make
you know what data might be out there how do
you trust it how do you help them trust it if
they're a consumer what kinds of analysis would
might be needed to support their decisions you
know what are the ethical considerations and
then finally there is a data science process
and trying to understand that process and
where you are in that process is important
we're going to walk through those questions um
in the context of a couple examples the first one
is one of the very first problems that we worked
or the very first partnerships that we created
when we started our research group about nine
years ago and this is within arlington virginia
arlington virginia is in northern virginia it
has about 240 000 in population it covers 26
square miles it has a pretty low unemployment
rate and a white population of 61 percent
so we started working with the arlington county
government and they had a particular problem in
question that they brought to us the problem was
they'd been hearing about the data revolution
and data science and they wanted to know how can
they develop data informed situational assessment
or situational awareness that could help
improve quality of life and services in the com
in the county and the very specific first
question came from the fire chief who really
started to understand about this data stuff and
what he wanted to know is would it be possible
to link together the fire ems data that gets
generated to administer fire ems 911 incidents
would it be possible to pull that data across
their data systems link it together end-to-end and
recreate the incidents in the data because he felt
that if you could do that that data could be used
to build an understanding to build some analyses
to help them understand resource allocation
resource utilization and training so we
said sure why not let's see what we can do
so the next question that comes to mind was
what kinds of decisions was he interested in
was he interested in strategic decisions
trying to put this information together to help
inform things more strategically future planning
future placement of fire boxes and fire stations
was he interested in anticipatory decisions
trying to understand what are changes that
that might occur over the county over
the coming you know weeks months years
that might change the direction that they go with
different things or were they looking for tactical
decision making like a real-time uh board that
would tell you what's going on in a 911 situation
well it turns out that it was
the anticipatory and strategic
area that the fire chief was interested in they
didn't really want or need help in managing you
know on the fly these incidents what they wanted
to do was to collect them and re-evaluate what
had happened through a corpus of data by mashing
up the 911 incident data with socioeconomic data
so what data are they really talking about and
what are going to be trust issues with these data
so that brings me to ask the question what
are data and i like to think of data as a fact
assumed to be a matter of direct observation
in other words you need to observe something
questions are needed to inform direct observation
so we're kind of back to this importance of these
questions that inform our problems and then once
you have a sense of what that direct observation
is you need measurements you need to convert that
observation into facts and those facts are the
data well let's see what we have well today we
can observe a tremendous amount of information
you know infrastructure environment people
and many more boxes should be on this chart
historically we tended to treat these
things you know kind of in siloed pieces
of information we built infrastructure
models environmental models people models
but today the exciting thing is we can blend
this all together and really mash it up
the measurement we're talking about is we're
really talking about identifying archival data
existing data you know not necessarily primary
collected data but secondary sources and
measurement is about data repurposing just data
repurposing on steroids but it's important to
think about how the data are born that you're
repurposing it did it come from a design data
collection is it administrative data that's just
out there to administer an organization and that's
going to be the lion's share of our data for this
particular problem is it data that just is out
there you know on opportunity data on the internet
and other places that you can scrape and pull in
and then a fourth bucket of data that's incredibly
important is procedural data which could be
the procedure that runs the stoplight on the on
on the street or the different laws and procedures
and policies that govern an organization it's
important to know how that interfaces in with
what you're doing okay so here's our data and i
want you to look at the middle flow here to begin
with the flows of events an incident occurs 9-1-1
boom it comes in it goes to a call center the
communication center a unit is to pet dispatched
a unit arrives at the location they do whatever
they need to do the incident is closed and then
there's some post-incident reporting so that's
what's happening well there's data systems that
exist that administer every one of those steps
what doesn't exist is a magic little id number
that takes you from one data system to the next
to the next to the next that's not how they
were built and that's not what their function
that's not what their function is designed
for then there's also other data like american
community survey data or social media other data
that if i have locations whether it's the housing
locations or the dispatch route i can now start
to think about how to attach these data together
so that's what we were confronted with and
we wanted to try to recreate these incidents
so what we did we took all those data sources
and we just started to line them up in time
and on date to see if we could identify and now
start to trace units through their actions and
trace the reporting through you know connect
it up with an incident and we actually were
successfully able to do this here's a picture
of where you're seeing these data linked
which had great relevancy to police chiefs because
they also started to see their unit utilization
i can't say that it rocks my boat but i
did you know we did this to get the data
reposit to get the data set that we needed to
have all these corpus of incidents end to end
but it turns out a simple visualization
like this spoke volumes to the fire chiefs
so the next thing to think about when you're
thinking about data acumen is what types of
analyses can you do or are needed to inform
the decisions that you want to try to make
so now we have this corpus of data that
we've linked together it was no trivial
task to do that but now we have something
we can work with well types of analyses they
come in flavors we have descriptive analyses
prescriptive analytics which really summarizes
and represents the data that you have a
great way to check did you link it properly
data then from descriptive can be used for
explanatory studies this might help you
test causal hypotheses constructs theories or
you might be wanting to use it for predictive
analytics that really helps you try to
predict something in the future and then
the other thing that you like to do if you can is
to create simulations possibly from the data to
help ask what if questions contrafactual analysis
of the data and information and in our institute
we spend a lot of time building platforms
that help you query and study this and then
prescriptive analytics is sort of the holy grail
that people would like to get to where you're
really trying to do stochastic optimization over
constraints that are placed on predictive models
well in our example the early thing that we
did was to take this beautiful data that we'd
linked together and just tried to draw some early
data insights that we could feed back to the fire
chief and his folks and the very first thing
was to just look at how much time were they
spending on call because minutes matter in this
situation so in this particular case they could
see how their different units were functioning
and how much time they were spending on call
it's a log scale on minutes by the way on
the vertical axis then the next thing that
they were really interested in was what about
the response time because again minutes matter
and particularly response time from the
different fire stations with all of the
fire stations behaving similarly or were
there certain ones where there could perhaps
improve their response time and so this was
another descriptive um picture that you see here
and you know you look at this and you don't really
see much going on because the data are noisy
and so you know we looked at this and thought
well okay this is still descriptive can i take
this data and now do something explanatory with it
and that was the next step and in the explanatory
analysis it was to disentangle the fact that we
had different kinds of incidents some were fires
some were ems some were critical things that
were going to end up at the hospital some were
you know somebody stubbed their toe so there was a
whole different set in types of incidents going on
and different incidents lead to different
apparatus different kinds of vehicles different
kinds of equipment that gets sent so putting
that together and developing a statistical
model that can control for all of these things
presented a pretty different picture back to
the fire chief now you see there's very
significant differences in response time by
the different stations and across the area across
the county which then gave them an opportunity
to delve further into trying to understand
why that is and what they could do about it
well what about ethical considerations and i'm
going to flip to a slightly different example
with the fire department for that but ethical
considerations first let me just remind you
what they are and this whole series this year
that jack and company are having is around
ethics and ethics and ai or ethics and data
science and this is just one of my most favorite
examples about why we have to worry about ethics
and you probably many of you probably already know
this example back in 2016 when amazon went
to their one day service and they decided
what parts of different cities were
they going to roll this service out to
they looked at their data which had to do with
sales and sales volume in different areas and they
decided which neighborhoods they would roll this
out to and unbeknownst to them their data analysis
completely defined the racial boundaries in
these cities um so that was sort of an aha moment
we have to really worry about what are different
models and these are ai models in this case what
are they doing you know are they really capturing
what you want to capture are they capturing other
features that are somewhat unintended so really
thinking through your data and what possible
biases could exist there well we have things
to guide us we have the fabulous belmont report
that i'm assuming most of you are familiar with
which lays out the foundation for institutional
review boards and the common rule that governs
research in the united states when it comes to
having respect for persons beneficence and
justice and when you think of the belmont report
it's laying the framework on what you need to be
worried about thinking about we go you know the
training if you've never taken institutional
review board training i encourage you to do
it because it takes you through a lot of thought
processes around ethics particularly when you're
focusing on human subjects well not all of our
data are about human subjects and not all of our
focus is necessarily human subjects and it turns
out that there's a wonderful report that came out
in 2012 it was commissioned by the department of
homeland security that we find interesting that's
pretty underutilized and under recognized and
it's called the menlo report and in this report
what they were tasked to do was to take the
belmont principles and look at how they apply
in an information communication technology
setting and they extended the principles
to include respect for law and public interest
and this has a focus on research with human
harming potential so i encourage you to look at
this report it was a great uh committee largely
of pretty well-known computer scientists that
worked on this but it takes belmont and maps
it into this other space so between these two
reports you can start to create the picture
of data science ethics because data
science involves both of those aspects
and if you add to that you know some of what you
know and have learned from ethical guidelines
from professional societies read what
experts have written around ethical questions
you can start to think about what are the
questions and the ethical issues you need to be
worried about during the whole life
cycle of a data science project
and we've done that and the link here takes you to
a data science ethics checklist that we've created
that is a living document for us during
the course of our projects where we're
continually revisiting these issues and
at each stage of the data science process
we're asking questions and we're asking
questions around ethics around you know what
are these data actually representing who's being
missed what are the biases as i'm developing my
methods and algorithms you know where are the
biases in those uh different methods as well
well back to our fire department
this is a slightly different example
because i think it highlights the ethical issues
quite well in this particular case the fire chief
another question that he came to us with
he said you know we go out once a year
there's a week where we go door to door and
we ask people to invite us into their homes
so that we can check their smoke detectors
first of all do they have an adequate number
and the ones that they have are they working
if not the fire uh fighters will actually
change them out for you well they typically
would just sort of go wherever with no particular
strategy of which neighborhood to go to they
would go when they had some time during that
week whatever they were sort of closest to and
so the question was is there a better way to do
that and so you can already begin to see some of
the ethical issues of just doing it where you are
and so they gave us the data that they had for
a few years of where they went in the county
and what they found and we were able to take
that and put a machine learning model together
and actually map out and we were able
to match that up with other things like
how old the housing units were
other different socioeconomic
um indicators across the county you know again
at these different locations on a census block
group basis and we were actually able to build
a model a predictive model that told them
where they would have the highest percentage of
homes that perhaps were in need of their help
now that in and of itself is also a bit of an
ethical issue because is it fair to just go to the
red areas here or should they really be spreading
out across the entire county so we were able to
provide them this information and then encourage
them to do a mix of where they were going and then
in the next year they you know gave us they went
out and also provided the data back and we were
really pleased that our model actually did quite
well and we were able to provide them an even
you know better updated set of information of
what the status looked like across the county
so with that this brings us to the
last question in our data acumen
set of questions and i'm going to turn
it over to stephanie at this point
thank you sallie um that sets the stage nicely
for moving on to our data science framework i'm
going to introduce our data science framework our
community engagement process and then a case study
that demonstrates the power of data acumen
from the beginning to the end of the project
much as sallie does did but in a slightly
different approach so to address our data science
problems for the public good we've developed this
data science framework to guide our processes
and it provides for us a comprehensive
and rigorous way for doing data science
i like to think about it as having
three main components so you have
communications and dissemination on the left
you have the analytics in the middle and then
you have your ethics and recently we've been
thinking about adding ethics and equity review
on the right hand thing on the right-hand side
and all three are essential to achieving the
data acumen um and they're also intertwined
and the reason for the two bars along the side
is that we are doing that at every stage
of the analytics process so the analytics
component emphasizes working in collaboration with
our consumers sallie's talked about that a lot um
but the important thing here is that we're trying
to develop a shared understanding of the context
of what are the real questions that they want and
we're trying to do that in a way that is focused
unbiased research questions as the first step and
i like to say that this is often the hardest part
of the project because defining seemingly
clear and unbiased questions is challenging
as you all know um but it's achieved through our
conversations with stakeholders the consumers the
experts and of course the review of the literature
as well and then throughout the process we are
always communicating both internally with the
team as well as sharing our results externally
because of course that's where you get your
feedback and we also are also seeking feedback
about the ethical dimensions along the way so it's
an iterative process that's why there's the circle
in the middle um so it's not a linear process
at all but each step informs the other both
prior and and going forward and what i love about
our data science framework is that it really
helps you say okay we've defined these clear
questions now what's next and going through
our data discovery our data ingestion and
governance the wrangling of the data and then
our statistical modeling and analysis and fitness
for use so next slide sallie and then along with
our data science framework we've um through
working many problems with many communities
we've developed a community engagement process and
again it the community participates in asking and
answering questions i think that's really uh part
of the beauty of this process is building their
capacity to do that to know that they they
have the power uh to ask and get answers to
these questions and work with us to develop those
answers as well um and so looking at this wheel
the outer wheel is the continuous interaction and
communications across stakeholders and communities
and then the middle wheel is more of the data
learning process as we um have defined you know
you're you you know you start by you're working
with the community to discover today the data
to integrate the data to act on those measure and
then and evaluate and then redirect so that's why
you know the continuous cycle and
then the frontier between the two
represents the active collaboration between all
partners and then of course in the middle is
our rigorous data science framework that guides
the data science work next slide sallie so now i
want to present an end-to-end example of posing
and answering the data accumulating questions
similar to what sallie did um as you know as well
as integrating that with our community engaged
that process in describing that process as
it unfolds um next slide so the road this is
going to be about the roanoke valley allegheny
region and it's a beautiful region it has five
counties and three cities in western virginia
and sort of the anchor is the city of roanoke
it has a population of about 300 000 a little over
300 000 people and an unemployment rate of 2.8
and it is predominantly white although it is
um that number keeps dropping um but not not
as low as what we saw in arlington um next slide
so we worked with the roanoke valley allegheny
region commission i'm just going to refer to
them as the commission throughout and they
are the consumer in this case um and they are one
of 21 planning commissions in virginia and so we
asked them you know what is what is the problem
you want to solve and what are your questions
um next slide and what they were interested
in was building a workforce um they said to us
you know we have dozens of universities around
us within you know 25 50 miles yet only five
percent of the graduates actually stay in
our region how do we attract them um to stay
you know and and become product you know have
their families here um have you know work work
in the labor force in the roanoke region and
so that led us we thought actually when they
initially asked us the question we were going
to do a very much labor market kind of analysis
um but when they started talking about what what
would it take to attract experienced workers
from other regions as well as to keep the recent
graduates we realized that that was the question
that we wanted to ask what are the factors that
make an area attractive to workers and families
and what challenges does the region face so the
next slide sallie so what kind of decisions need
to be made the next step was to see if we could
frame this issue to develop a strategic plan they
were interested in a developing a strategy that
would help them make their region more attractive
to attract workers both singles and families so we
first looked at what other communities were doing
we also explained explored with the commission
how to frame their question in the data context
so next slide sallie um so we asked
what kinds of data do you have available
and why should i trust the data and part
of our process of course is always to
understand the quality of the data and that
helps us understand and trust it as well
next slide so what we did was we sat down
with the commission and created a data map
and this is a great tool for developing sort
of a conceptual understanding of the project
and gets both you know the consumer and and the
researchers working together and really rolling
up their sleeves to say okay what is it that we're
trying to address so we did in fact focus on the
behavior in the labor force and we decided that
there were some internal labor force challenges
and external labor force challenges that we
were looking at so on the internal labor force
side we looked at things such as drug use and
prisoner re-entry and child care costs and others
things like internal issues such as access to
training and the ability to earn certificates
and then we also wanted to look at factors
that were external to the labor force so
things about you know are primarily focused on the
community so how nice is it to live in the region
are there parks is it walkable are there cultural
events and what about public transportation
and commuting how hard is it to commute um
that we did know was one of the challenges
in the area as well so in the middle of this data
map is um you know the households and the labor
force comes out of the households and of course
there's the eight cities or five five counties and
three cities that make up the whole region and
they're primarily concerned with the workforce
development and attracting industry as well as
families to support jobs in that industry as well
next slide sallie so we undertook a data
discovery process and the data map definitely
helped us guide that data discovery because we
saw the kinds of data we wanted now we needed to
look and understand or or it's a process that we
under undertake to see what's out there what what
data are out there in the wild that might inform
our our uh pro our project or a problem we don't
just rely on the data that we are familiar with we
really like to do this exploratory stage because
we uncover some really interesting sources of data
that help or help inform the research and provide
new insights into addressing the research
questions so we when we do that next slide
um we actually undertake some what we call just
descriptive analysis to begin looking at what
these data sources look like and this is just a
little bit some of the data that we were examining
we use multiple sources of data always
the traditional american community survey
but also data from the u.s department of
education the virginia employment commission
cdc and just many many other sources as you
can see and what's useful about this step is
not just the data discovery but we also begin
to learn about the issues facing the region
so we learned about there was food insecurity
and obesity there's low population growth
and there's changes in income and unemployment
so all of that can affect how attractive a region
region is um next slide and then we also
wanted to use some place-based data as well
um so one of the things because we
knew transportation was a challenge
we map public transportation car ownership and
proximity to training sites or other services
such as drug treatment facilities and we
discovered that most of those facilities
were primarily located in the roanoke the city of
roanoke versus just closely related to that and
so if you lived you know in one of the counties
it was further to get there and transportation
is definitely an issue especially for a lot of
the workers and so that was one of the problems
that we identified and just being able to map
that data um you know looking at the public
transportation as well as the car ownership you
can see that you know getting to these sites is uh
probably you have to have a car a car that's
going to work and get you there um so anyway
that that obviously lays the um basis for some
policy actions there as well um next slide
uh so the next question uh we asked is what's the
type of the analysis that we're going to be doing
and we can go on to the next slide so
what we wanted to do was to explore with
the commission what might be useful metrics
and how might we integrate uh these data and
recall they had talked about attractiveness and
how they were interested in using data to tell how
attractive their region is both the singles and
both the families we can go on to the next slide
um and so in this slide what we did was we
created these composite indicators using
some synthetic data that we had created from the
american community survey and local property data
and then we mapped it by magisterial districts
and those are voting districts essentially but
we live in the commonwealth of virginia so they
call them magisterial districts but we did that
at a sub-county subsidy level to approximate
neighborhoods so that we're getting down and we
can actually study different parts of the county
or different parts of the city and what we can see
actually when we look at these composites which
were composed of data for about transportation
housing and then the community is that the day
you know singles are very different than families
um singles are more interested in living in urban
environments so that means they're more likely to
live around the city of roanoke while families
are more likely to live or be spread more out
throughout the um throughout the region and that
might be you know they want larger homes or more
yard or the schools depending on you know the
quality of the schools and the different areas
as well so this provided a tremendous amount of
insight um into in for the commission to begin
to able begin to think about what kind of
policies that they wanted to think about
so i did i think i forgot to add that the lighter
the color the more attractive is the area so
that's obviously for the singles the lighter the
color here and the light of the color for families
you can see where they were interested in
living in so we worked with the next slide
we worked with the commission because we were
also concerned about the ethical issues about
our research and we had conversations with the
commission with uh on the county and city planners
the service providers and just people in different
parts of the region and there was a lot of
sensitivity about drug rehabilitation and prisoner
re-entry into the community and workforce and they
were just concerned that that might define their
region as not being attractive but the commission
decided that these issues were too important to
ignore and that policies are needed to support
the populations so it still provided motivation
that they needed to address the issues broadly
uh but also focused in on training and some of
the other issues as well because these um a lot
of this leads to of course a potential workforce
um that would would populate that um so what they
did was uh i guess we just went through this slide
but this go goes back of course to get back to
each of our data science checklist where at
each stage you know again to reiterate we assess
our research questions our data sources our
models for implicit biases we had lots of
conversations with stakeholders i talked about the
sensitivity about certain groups and decided that
these were too important to ignore next slide
so we were pleased to see that in the following
year when they developed their strategies
that they had addressed many of the issues
that uh we had pointed out through our composite
indicators as well as looking at the individual
composites as well that made up and you can see
they really they actually align quite nicely with
how we created the data and the indicators um
they did say that when they had worked with
other groups before like one group had given
them a list of 100 indicators that they could
use to track like progress in their region and
they just said it was overwhelming and so they
found the use of these composites really helpful
and then creating you know these maps that a
sub a lower geography than just counties and
cities that they could actually understand the
different areas uh was enormously helpful
to them uh so let's uh last slide sallie
so to wrap up um this summarizes a lot of what
you heard today um data science as we know is
foundational to our economy and lives and we are
passionate about requiring or not requiring but
teaching people are building
capacity especially communities
especially with about their level of data acumen
and that allows them to make good judgments
about the use of data to support their problem
solutions that is our definition as sallie noted
um but understanding the basics of data science
and data acumen not only um allows us to work
with communities but allows them to build their
capacity to ask questions use data and to make
data informed data informed decisions so at the
heart of our work is our data science framework
and our cld3 our community learning through
data-driven discovery process and that integrates
our communications and ethics you know across
the analytical analytical parts of the projects
and these processes they help us to accelerate
accelerate our work and then importantly for us
it also helps us just identify our next steps so
you know as we go through the process it's a guide
to help us and a reminder to incorporate ethics
and communications and dissemination into our work
so both are a scaffold also that allows us
to document our work in a transparent way
so um we think that it's really important
and you can tell that we're passionate
about incorporating ethics into our research
and we hope you found this useful thank you
sallie and stephanie thank you so much that
was a wonderful overview i really enjoyed
hearing about your data science framework
that looks like a very useful tool for
kind of solving you know identifying a problem and
identifying data and going through a process of
iterating on that to come up with solutions um
one of the things that i noticed that sallie
had shown is uh the belmont report and for
those of us in biomedical science if you've
ever had to do any irb training the belmont
report is something that we all know about
the thing i thought was a little bit ironic
about sallie's slide is that the cut the the
picture that you showed of the belmont report
comes from the for forgotten books collection
which i thought was rather interesting because
clearly the belmont report has given rise to
um many other things the menlo report i wasn't
very aware of um but i was also interested maybe
you could discuss a little bit about how the
evolution of these kind of ethical principles
that were embodied in the belmont report in the
common rule before that and now the menlo report
how this dovetails with data openness and
open science team science and how those that
interact with data ethics and the considerations
thereof so steph i'm gonna punt that one to you
okay stephanie if you can't answer that
one so let me rephrase the question and
make sure that i understand it because i
was thinking sallie was going to take this
so the um thinking about sort of the belmont
report and then the continuum along with the menlo
report and how that integrates with sort of all
the facets of data science including team science
i mean i think it it definitely an open science
and all of that i think that it definitely raises
awareness um and issues about you know what
the challenges are in data science especially
when you are integrating data and a lot of times
uh on the surface it may seem that you're taking
data sources that are um just transparent or
that you can use because they seem to be publicly
available but there is a lot of concern about you
know you take your cell phone data and you combine
it with your twitter data and then all of a sudden
you you marry it with the local property data like
you know can you begin to identify people or does
it bring does it highlight certain groups in a way
that you may not that is not positive or in a way
that doesn't contribute to the conversation and
so the menlo report spends a lot of time talking
about like some of the challenges or things that
can happen when you begin to integrate the data um
so i guess those are the challenges that you might
have to address when you're looking at open source
data or we're also just working as a team on that
so i'm sure that sallie can probably
answer that in a more cohesive way
i think that the i you one of the things that
we found um interesting when we when we started
our research group and when we started
you know working on these problems um with
computer scientists data you know now called data
scientists and with the communities is that a lot
of computer scientists and data scientists who
uh you know that are out there working different
problems they're they're they're not aware of
an irb they don't go through that training like
jack you and others in the biomedical field have
done um that that's that's just not part of what
they've had to do they haven't had to think of
their data that way we've really been encouraging
more of that to take place and the other thing
that is interesting to us is that as we've been
working with communities because we work with a
lot of local governments and local communities
that's not in their vernacular either that that's
just not part of what they worry about even
though they're knitting together all of this data
about you know people places the economy and so
i think it's really useful to have something
like this ethics checklist that we that we've
talked about that we've developed and
with your partners with your sponsors
part of the project team that you you all go
through some of this together and have these
discussions and to the question that caitlin
asked about why do we think the menlo report
hasn't really been taken up by data scientists
that's one of our big mysteries we don't know
because it was sort of developed by this team of
computer scientists now perhaps we don't have all
the ins and outs of why or how the department of
homeland security asked for it but i will say in
addition in addition to the report that nicole
has linked you to in the chat there's also a
follow-up where they do some case studies and
we can find that and share that with you it's
it's pretty fascinating and we wish that more
people would focus in on some of these things
i know i always think about one of these days i
just want to pick up the phone or send an email
to all those computer scientists and say what
happened you know why is this probably buried
probably isn't the first time it won't be the last
time that some you know commissioned report sort
of didn't really catch fire but um but it's
interesting and again i didn't wasn't very
aware of it um hopefully some of our data
science colleagues will now be inspired to
go and look at it and see how it maps onto some
of the work that they're doing um in particular
i noticed that after you guys have you know you've
scoped out what the problem is and then you start
asking about the availability of data so that you
can kind of go through a mapping operation of how
does that data map onto your problem what are
some of the things that you look for in order
to be able to trust that that data is valid
it's showing you what it's you know it says
it's a measure is it really measuring what it
says it's measuring how do you trust it how do
you know that it's sufficiently large enough
to represent the catchment area of you know of
the county that you're trying to map what are
some of those things that you guys consider
so so jack first i'd say that you know we
have a pretty uh structured process the data
discovery process that we've developed
over the over the years and it starts
by you know kind of getting the team together
and just encouraging people to open their mind
and their imaginations and make a wish list if
they have if you could have any data under the sun
to help support the problem that you're working on
what would you want and to just start writing that
down don't worry about if it exists or not just
write it down and then once we do that we develop
a screening process where we're going to now start
to go see if we can find any of these sources
but we'll have screening questions so that we
don't waste too much time trying to go after some
data if it's not going to meet the time frame some
of the variables that might be relevant here so we
actually you know put a screening tool together to
help screen the different sources and you know in
one of them you know one element of the screening
tool would be you know in what time frame might
i be able to develop the data sharing agreement
for this data because if it's going to take three
years and my problem i have to get done in a year
it's not going to be helpful so so we sort of so
we have this sort of formal process but then as
we get the data as we start acquiring the data
you know we really do worry about fitness
for use and fitness for use is a function of
how the data is going to feed into a model or
an analysis as well as how complete the data
are and so we worry a lot and we have
conversations around coverage and bias
who's left out of this data do i even can i
even tell who might be left out of this data
and the acknowledgement of that is really
important because it's we may still use it but
at least we acknowledge and we have documented
what the limitations are in the interpretation
of whatever analyses come out of this and also
it's important to note that don't waste time
wrangling data that you might not use i might have
a big data file or a big data set or a big survey
i'm not going to clean it all up i'm just going
to really focus on those elements and clean
them to the point that i need for the analysis
that i'm going to support and a great example
is we work a lot with housing stock and housing
data and also multiple listing service data and
in the multiple listing service data they
have hundreds of variables that they collect
um but they're very it's very uneven the quality
of the data because to a realtor some data is more
important than others and we have a situation
where they collect zoning codes for their for
their properties but they don't tend to pay a
lot of attention to getting those codes right
and a lot of what we care about is is
it residential or not and it turns out
if they simply got an r in the in the zoning
code and the rest of the numbers who cares
r meant it was residential so we could take
this incredibly noisy data rather than throw
it out we could get the dichotomous mapping that
we wanted just by being smart by understanding
what the data quality issues were and just to add
on to that i think the fitness for use sometimes
can be a simple benchmarking or that can almost
be as creative as the ethics questions as well on
trying to figure out that often sometimes can be a
qualitative analysis or it can be quantitative if
you have something that you can compare to but as
with all of this it's as much an art as a science
that that's the truth one thing i i noticed um
sallie you were mentioning um you're working with
uh you know county level um first responder
data and uh you noted that um there was no say
continual id that kind of followed somebody
throughout the trajectory of the thing
but you had to start all this data but i was
wondering at what point that stops and in the
sense of the first responders their measure of
success were okay the victim of the accident
was successfully delivered to the hospital where
they could get further treatment and then that
was that was it they they checked the box and
they're done but it starts another process at
the level of the hospital where okay patient
is now admitted and then they're going to go
and so you've got this sort of chain of data
that's you know may start and stop with one
entity then it migrates to the next one and if
only you had that continuous stream you could
actually measure the the efficacy of how the first
responders did did they treat the wound properly
so that treatment could be affected and the person
survived or did something terrible happen to them
when the first responders didn't do it right and
the person died you know is it that kind of thing
and i was just kind of commenting or wondering
if you could comment on how these kind of chains
of data might be uh leveraged um in something
like your data science framework for example
right that's such a great question now for the
first responders their window into the world
ends at the emergency room yeah you know that they
deliver the patient to the emergency room and then
they're done you know and and then you know
yet you're right it would be so wonderful to
be linking this through and learning so much more
and the first responders would love to do that too
but there's all but there's all different issues
that happen as soon as it hits the hospital right
and yeah but the one thing that i would say if we
could you know if we could develop that project
that allows us to cross that chasm it would
be exciting and we don't have to worry about
having all these little unique identifiers to link
this data we were able to demonstrate by having
these administrative systems that were disjoint
across this just across the path of the event
of the incident that we've linked together that
we can be smart data science can help us figure
out how to link the right data together so if
we could just begin to be getting that you know
emergency room data we would have you know
we would have different ways we could we
could um link it into the other data without
having to have some big you know data system
developed to do that i guess that's my point
that standardization is not needed on all of
these things data science helps us get past that
but that would be wonderful i mean that would be
the wonderful thing but that's again where we
hit a hit up against um just the hipaa medical
side that we don't hit up against in the ems
data although i think when we were trying to
do this this was like 2014 2015 and things have
started to really change it seems like even
hospitals are becoming more open about sharing
their data as long as it's kept confidential so
but we we haven't gone back to try that yet well i
certainly hope that they do because that that is a
wonderful opportunity for sort of the approach
that you took where you're temporarily trying
to align these different data types to see if you
can identify correspondence between them and then
allow you to bridge that chasm otherwise you have
this weird discontinuity that you have to then
you know oh i don't have a identifier at any rate
it sounds like it would be a maybe tractable kind
of thing just being investigating or maybe
in charlottesville where the hospital's more
willing to share the data than they are maybe in
other other areas as well maybe maybe in roanoke
they're not so interested i don't know so what is
this arlington but still yeah arlington arlington
one of the things we one of the things we were
able to look at which was pretty interesting
was when that when an incident when a call comes
in they sort of make an assessment of what it
is so that they can determine what to dispatch
right and we actually did have them data of what
they thought it was and what it was you know when
their window into it ended and those things didn't
line up quite as well as they had expected which
is really useful information to the fire chief
right they have to make quick decisions and then
when they arrive it's often something different
i can imagine you know somebody's oh yeah my my
arm hurts oh okay you did something to your arm
and then it turns out oh no it's a heart attack
right obviously you would have taken them to maybe
a different location if you had known that yeah
all sorts of interesting data challenges well
sallie and stephanie thank you so much for sharing
your um your process with us and uh several really
interesting examples that i think you know even
though you the the areas you focused on were not
necessarily biomedical per se but all of those
general ideas and how one evaluates data how it
goes through your data science framework process
um those are all directly relevant to how people
deal with data from biomedicine and especially um
keeping it ethical and thinking ethically about
how that data gets used so i want to thank you
so much for sharing your thoughts with us today
i want to thank everybody who joined us and
i want to thank wish everybody a very happy
uh friday and uh do enjoy your weekend we'll see
you all next week have a great weekend thank you